a senior Justice Department official
tells CBS News that Special Counsel
Robert Muller is not expected to deliver
his final report on the Russia
investigation for at least a week
president Trump will have another
significant legal distraction while he
is in Vietnam his longtime personal
lawyer Michael Cohen is scheduled to
testify before Congress Paula Reed is at
the White House looking ahead to Cohn's
testimony Paula good morning good
morning lawmakers from both parties say
first and foremost they want to ask
Cohen why he lied about a trump real
estate deal in Moscow last time he
testified before Congress and they want
to ask him whether the president
directed him to do so now a source close
to Cohen says he will not discuss the
special counsels Russia investigation
during his public hearing on Wednesday
he's still cooperating with Muller but
he could discuss that in private
sessions with congressional
investigators but they'll still be
plenty of other hot topics to ask him
about including the president's business
practices possible campaign finance
violations the Trump Foundation and
Cohen's allegation that the president
has tried to intimidate Cohen by
threatening his family now president
Trump has dismissed Cohen as a liar and
not a credible witness Cohen has plead
guilty to lying to Congress as well as
to campaign finance violations related
to hush money payments paid to women who
alleged have affairs of the president
Cohen begins a three-year prison term in
early May
Nora married Paula thank you so much